"Herr Jesus,
ich bitte dich, gib mir die Kraft."
"Hilf mir, dass das die letzten
Dormicum meines Lebens sind. Amen."
Reto will endlich weg von den Drogen.
Zum wiederholten Mal abgestürzt,
gibt es nur noch eines:
den Gang in die Klinik.
Der spielsüchtige Cahit
hat seinen Führerausweis verloren.
Damit ist er sogar
seinen Job als Pizzakurier los.
Ich bin jetzt der Pechvogel -
oder wie nennt man das?
Samira ist fitnesssüchtig
und hat eine schwere Essstörung.
Zu Hause wiegt sie ihr Essen ab.
Seit dem Eintritt in die Klinik muss
sie lernen, wieder normal zu essen.
Ich habe extrem Mühe,
gewisse Dinge zu essen.
Ich sehe den Sinn dahinter nicht.
Sie alle wollen eine Veränderung.
Weg von der Sucht,
hinein in ein neues Leben.
* Sie atmet schwer. *
Die Klinik Selhofen in Burgdorf.
Reto wartet darauf,
aufgenommen zu werden.
* Vereinzelte Geigenklänge *
(Lallend) Was hat er gesagt,
wer noch kommt?
Guten Tag!
Mein Name ist Gerber.
- Grüessech, Frau Gerber.
Ich mache mit Ihnen den Eintritt.
- Das ist super.
Das kann ich selbst ...
Geht das?
- Ja, ja.
Heute bin ich nicht so verladen
wie die anderen Male.
Sie müssen hierherkommen,
in diese Richtung.
Ja.
Sie dürfen das Gepäck
hier hinstellen.
Reto ist nicht zum ersten Mal hier.
Stellen Sie es hier drauf. Tipptopp.
Jemand schaut dann noch kurz rein.
Wir gehen wieder nach vorne.
Wir schauen, was möglich ist, oder?
Mal eine Zigarette rauchen,
wenn's möglich wäre.
Das möchten Sie sehr gerne.
Ich rufe oben an.
Jemand soll rasch etwas bringen.
Fabienne Gerber
ist Pflegefachfrau in der Klinik.
Gut, also, setzen Sie sich trotzdem.
Sie will herausfinden,
was Reto alles intus hat.
Etwas getrunken haben Sie schon.
- Schon noch.
Erst kurz bevor Sie abgeholt wurden
oder schon am Morgen?
(Lallend) Nein, eigentlich
schon die ganze Nacht.
Und sonst noch?
Was haben Sie sonst noch genommen?
(Lallend) Und sonst?
Dormicum?
- Ja.
Ja, das ist das.
- Mhm.
Dazu ein- oder zweimal noch Kokain.
- Ja.
Einfach zusammen nimmt man es,
zusammen.
Hat es nicht gehalten?
Es ist einfach
ein fertiger Seich ...
... mit dieser Sucht.
Man müsste noch
Administratives erfassen.
Wir haben gedacht,
wir gehen zuerst mal rauf,
messen noch mehr Vitalzeichen
und machen einen Alkoholtest.
Das Administrative
machen wir dann später.
Tipptopp.
- Gut, also.
Dormicum ist Retos Problemdroge.
Der Wirkstoff Benzodiazepin
macht ihn extrem träge.
* Piepsen *
Gut, tipptopp. Der analysiert nun.
Was analysiert er denn?
Wie viel Alkohol Sie ...
Wie viel Promille.
- Ja.
Es steht "Analysierung". 1 Promille.
- Das ist ja nichts.
Wir werden später
sicher noch einmal nachmessen,
ob es noch steigt oder wieder fällt.
Hat jemand auf mich gewartet?
Wir haben gewartet.
Ich nehme den Becher raus.
Gut, tipptopp, also.
(Lallend) Ich habe gepinkelt
und gemacht.
Schauen Sie mal:
Morphin wird angezeigt.
- Ja.
THC zeigt an.
Und Kokain zeigt an.
- Ja, das zeigt es auch an.
Geht's noch mit Stehen?
- Ja, ja.
Ja?
- Problemlos.
Also ...
- Ich tue nur etwas komisch.
Sie tun etwas komisch?
Erfahrungsgemäss
kommt das häufig vor:
Die Leute erhalten den Termin
des Eintrittstages und wissen,
dass man hier abstinent oder halt
mit einer Null-Toleranz lebt.
Dann geben sie vorher
noch einmal Vollgas.
Das ist häufig der Fall.
Das erleben wir oft.
Also, Ihr Zimmer ...
Das wäre hier die Treppe rauf
und dann geradeaus.
Haben Sie gesehen? Es ist sogar
schon angeschrieben. Die 213.
Ja, super geil.
Das Gepäck ist auch schon da.
Sie können sich nachher
etwas hinlegen.
Ja, doch.
- Also.
Wir machen uns auf den Weg
nach unten.  - Tipptopp.
Geht's die Treppe runter?
- Eh, klar.
(Lachend) Eh, klar!
Einfach gut festhalten.
Ich bin jetzt froh.
V.a. in erster Linie darum,
weil ich nicht mehr
den ganzen Tag alleine bin.
Auch wenn es mir manchmal
zu viel werden kann.
Es gibt diese Rückzugsorte
und alles ...
Dass du vielleicht zum letzten Mal
Dormicum genommen hast?
Ich will kein Dormicum mehr.
Weg mit dem verdammten Scheissdreck!
* Vereinzelte,
akzentuierte Geigenklänge *
Und das sage ich auch schon
zum 100'000. Mal.
* Entspannte Gitarrenmusik *
Der 46-jährige Cahit ist arbeitslos
und online-spielsüchtig.
Er will sich
zurück ins Leben kämpfen.
Sein erster Vorsatz: mehr Sport.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
Und?
- Streng.
Mega streng.
Für einen Kettenraucher wie ihn
sowieso.
Früher ging ich
zweimal in der Woche schwimmen.
Warum hast du aufgehört?
Nachdem ich zu rauchen anfing
und mit dem Dings ...
... dem Spiel ...
... mit diesen Spielautomaten,
die einfach ...
Ich hatte keine Zeit mehr.
Keine Zeit mehr.
Im Moment siehst du
mega glücklich aus.
Ja, baden ...
Wasser. Das mögen alle,
wie ein kleines Kind.
Nur mit Sport ist es für Cahit
nicht getan. Er will einen Job.
Eine Beschäftigung
würde ihm Halt geben
und wäre ein erster Schritt
aus seiner Spielsucht.
Mit alten Zeugnissen
geht es zur Stellenvermittlung.
Grüezi. Ich habe um 14 Uhr
einen Termin mit Herrn Mugglin.
Dabei auch ein Brief
des Strassenverkehrsamt.
Weil er bekifft Auto gefahren ist,
musste er den Ausweis
für unbestimmte Zeit abgeben.
Ich habe langsam
keinen Durchblick mehr.
Von 2016 habe ich auch etwas.
Diese Hiobsbotschaft
hört sein Berater zum ersten Mal.
Es ist irgendwie
ein Missverständnis, kann ich sagen.
D.h. im nächsten halben Jahr
ist äh ...
Eine Orientierung für eine Stellen-
suche als Chauffeur gestorben.
Ja, genau.
Das schon, ja. - Das schon.
- Mhm.
Gut.
Nein, nicht gut. Es ist blöd.
Ja, das schon, ja.
Wie gesagt,
zumindest abends konnte ich
4-5 Std. als Pizzakurier arbeiten.
Diese Chance habe ich jetzt auch ...
... nicht mehr.
Welche anderen Arbeiten
könnten Sie sonst erledigen?
Was für ... ja ...
Als Lagerist irgendwie.
Oder wie gesagt, so ...
... an der Tankstelle, z.B. Coop.
Wenn Sie können, schreiben Sie mir
die Bewerbungen für die Stellen
und wir schauen sie gemeinsam an.
- Okay.
Was meinen Sie, Herr Mugglin ...
Wenn wir denen schreiben,
dass ich einen Job suche
und deshalb
den Führerausweis benötige ...
Vielleicht gibt es
so eine Dings, äh ...
Dass sie mir
ein wenig entgegenkommen
und ich den Führerausweis
früher zurückbekomme.
Ich denke, der Weg, so wie ihn
die Polizei vorgeschlagen hat ...
Mhm. Verkehrsgesetz.
... ist der richtige.
Wieder einmal
alles von vorne beginnen.
Gut. - Dann haben wir es.
- Ja.
Ich bekomme eine Mail von Ihnen.
Danke, Herr Mugglin.
Alles Gute! - Danke.
- Viel Erfolg! - Danke.
Adieu.
- Adieu, einen schönen Tag.
Dass er seinen Ausweis
abgeben musste,
ist für mich ganz neu.
Entsprechend sind wir im Gespräch
nicht wirklich weitergekommen.
Wir sind einfach immer wieder ...
Das Abgeben des Führerausweises
und der nächsten Perspektive ...
Es endete immer wieder
bei seinem Wunsch,
als Chauffeur arbeiten zu können
und über seine Beziehungen
wieder als Pizzakurier zu arbeiten.
Damit dreht es sich im Kreis.
Obwohl er den Führerausweis los ist,
studiert Cahit
Stelleninserate für Chauffeurjobs.
Ich bin gerne immer unterwegs,
z.B. in einer Stadt.
Ich fahre gerne Auto.
Deshalb suche ich einen solchen Job.
Ich freue mich, wenn ich
in der Stadt herumfahren kann,
unter Menschen zu sein.
Lieber das, als ein Hilfsjob
in der Küche? - Genau.
Okay.
* Klagende Klänge *
* Strassenlärm *
* Sanfte, dumpfe Musik *
Seit zwei Wochen ist Samira
in der Klinik Barmelweid.
Hier soll sie
ihre Essstörung therapieren.
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist Reis mit Poulet.
Vieles, das aufs Tablett kommt,
passt ihr gar nicht.
Wie sieht es aus?
Fein, abgesehen von der Sauce,
wie ich es gesagt habe.
Das ist der Salat
und diese komische Creme da.
Das möchtest du nicht essen?
Ich werde es versuchen,
aber ich denke es nicht.
Beim Essen
will Samira nicht gefilmt werden.
Beim Ausfüllen des Protokolls
darf die Kamera wieder dabei sein.
Ich muss aufschreiben, was ich von
diesem Teller nicht gegessen habe.
Und ...
Ich finde es immer schwierig.
"Gefühle vor dem Essen
und nach dem Essen."
Also ich war sicher hungrig.
Unsicherheit.
Und im Moment
habe ich Bauchschmerzen.
Die Sauce liess ich sein.
Also die Salatsauce
und die Sauce zum Reis.
Ich habe das Fleisch gegessen.
Ich habe die Hälfte vom Reis
gegessen.
Er war ...
Er war ziemlich buttrig.
Ich habe einfach
die Hälfte gegessen.
Samira fällt es schwer,
den Ernährungsplan zu akzeptieren.
Tagsüber isst sie kaum etwas.
Später folgt der Rückschlag.
Es ist immer noch
derselbe Teufelskreis.
Ähm ...
Ich hatte gestern eine Fressattacke.
Ich ass alles,
was ich noch im Zimmer hatte.
Ähm, und ...
... eine ganze Packung Sugus
verdrückt.
Ich hatte solchen Heisshunger.
Jetzt ist mir ziemlich übel.
Ähm ...
Ich fürchte mich schon vor dem
Mittag. Keine Ahnung, was kommt.
Keine Ahnung,
was ich davon essen kann und werde.
Und, ähm ...
Ich vermisse das Gym.
Ich möchte ins Training.
Ich fühle mich so dick
und lauchig gleichzeitig.
Ich habe das Gefühl ...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiss, es ist Bullshit.
Ich höre nun auf zu labern.
Mit ihrer Therapeutin kann Samira in
der Klinik über ihre Situation reden.
Ich spüre, dass ich
eine Nullbock-Stimmung habe.
Ich muss irgendwie versuchen,
dagegen zu steuern, damit ich ...
Ähm ...
Das kennen wir ja ein Stück weit.
Manchmal läuft es gut und dann
kommen wieder Zweifel darüber,
ob es wirklich das Richtige ist.
- Mhm.
Für mich ist eigentlich ...
Solange das Gewicht nicht gross
runter, also nicht extrem runter-,
beziehungsweise
v.a. nicht raufgeht ...
D.h., es ist immer noch
recht abhängig vom Gewicht,
wie Sie sich fühlen.
Ganz weg ist es noch nicht.
Die Problematik ist schon noch da.
Ich merke, dass der Sport
mich noch stark beeinflusst.
Ich will weiterhin Sport machen,
aber vielleicht
in einem anderen Bezug.
Und zwar so, dass es nicht mehr
ein Zwang oder eine Sucht ist.
Das ist für mich schon noch sehr ...
Ich war letzte, vorletzte Woche
einen Tag krank
und konnte nicht trainieren.
Und dann ist gleich wieder alles
aus dem Ruder geraten.
Ja.
Im Nachhinein muss ich lachen,
aber eigentlich
ist es gar nicht lustig.
Diese inneren Prozesse ...
Der Aufbau einer Selbstakzeptanz:
Wer bin ich überhaupt?
Oder den eigenen Halt
in sich zu finden ...
Diese Themen
begleiten Frau * Piepton *
schon seit ihrer Kindheit.
Sie haben ihren Ursprung
schon in der frühen Kindheit.
Sie lassen sich nicht einfach so
von heute auf morgen ändern.
Das braucht Zeit.
In der Klinik muss sich Samira
an den Ernährungsplan halten
und darf nicht so viel trainieren
wie früher.
Aber wenn sie darf, verbringt sie
jede freie Minute mit Sport.
* Sanfter Popsong:
"Perfect" von Ed Sheeran *
Wenn man fünf Jahre lang
so intensiv Sport betrieben hat
und sich eigentlich
gar nichts erlaubt hat,
dann ist es sehr, sehr, sehr
schwierig, davon loszukommen
und zu sagen:
"Heute habe ich keine Lust."
Es braucht keinen Grund.
* Luftiger Popsong:
"2002" von Anne-Marie *
# On the day we fell in love.
* Akzentuierte Geigenklänge *
Reto ist seit knapp einer Woche
in der Klinik.
Nach seinem Drogenrausch
beim Eintritt
steht eine erste Standortbestimmung
auf dem Programm.
Wie waren die ersten Tage?
Ist es gut gegangen?
Ja, also, äh ...
Den Umständen entsprechend schon,
ja.
Was ich einfach habe ...
Es dreht einfach wahnsinnig
in meinem Kopf.
Was halt alles kaputt ist
im Leben und so, oder.
Und, ja ...
Das ist einfach etwas ...
Sie machen sich fertig.
- Ja.
Mit diesen Selbstvorwürfen.
Das verstehe ich. Man wird wieder
wach und sieht den Scherbenhaufen.
Ja, genau.
- Das ist sehr hart.
Ein Stück weit finde ich,
dass es normal ist.
Man kann das nicht wegwischen.
Man hat versucht,
es mit den Substanzen wegzuwischen.
Jetzt ist es plötzlich da.
Manchmal muss man auch traurig sein.
Und nun ist schon der Eintritt
ein grosser Schritt,
aber auch diese Umstellung:
von den verschiedenen Substanzen
und dem Alkohol auf Rivotril.
Da braucht es auch
ein gewisses Einpendeln.
Ja.
Würden Sie mit Alkohol und Benzo
auf null gehen,
wäre das mehr als gefährlich,
das wissen Sie - Ja, ja.
Unser erster Job ist folgender:
Wir sammeln die vielen Substanzen,
die er einnimmt:
Bier, Starkbier, Wodka, Dormicum,
Lexotanil, Kokain und Cannabis.
Wir stellen um auf die Substanzen,
mit welchen wir den Entzug machen.
In unserem Fall ist das Rivotril.
Das ist mit Dormicum verwandt,
aber es wirkt einerseits
viel, viel länger.
D.h., es gibt stabile Blutspiegel,
nicht dieses Auf und Ab.
Andererseits hat es eine
ganz langsame Anflutungszeit.
Es fährt nicht ein und sorgt
für eine entsprechende Ruhe.
Haben wir einmal
die richtige Dosis gefunden -
woran wir im Moment noch sind -
gibt es eine Stabilisierung.
Dann senken wir das Rivotril
Schritt für Schritt.
Zum elften Mal
macht Reto hier den Entzug.
* Stimmengewirr *
Das war schon alles.
Das muss man nicht noch
zelebrieren und so.
Das Problem ist nicht auf Zack
gelöst, das ist nicht zu erwarten.
Sucht ist ein zirkulärer Prozess.
Man dreht immer wieder eine Runde.
Das Ziel
bei Herrn * Piepton * wäre,
dass die Runde
zu einer Aufwärtsspirale wird.
Und nicht, wie so häufig,
zu einer Abwärtsspirale.
Reto weiss, dass die nächsten Tage
schwierig werden -
und nicht nur diese.
* Langgezogener,
klagender Geigenklang *
Persönlich kenne ich sehr wenige,
die den Ausstieg geschafft haben.
Ich kenne mehr, die verreckt sind,
als solche,
die den Ausstieg geschafft haben.
Ein Wunder, dass ich noch lebe.
Das ist für mich
ein Zeichen von Gott.
Dass im Leben
noch etwas kommen soll,
sonst hätte ich nicht all
die Überdosen und das Zeug überlebt.
* Akzentuierter Geigenklang *
Zum Anfangen können Sie die
Unterlage unter Ihnen wahrnehmen.
Etwa vier- bis sechsmal die Woche
besucht Samira
verschiedene Therapiestunden.
In der Klangentspannung
soll sie sich möglichst wohlfühlen.
Hoi, Beauty.
Auch in der Therapie mit Alpakas.
Hallo!
In der Kunst- oder Bewegungstherapie
geht es um positive Erlebnisse.
Samira soll lernen,
sich selbst wieder zu akzeptieren.
Und es geht aufwärts.
Einen schönen guten Morgen!
Diese Woche ist auf jeden Fall schon
um einiges besser als die letzte.
Und mit dem Essen ...
Ja, da kommen immer verschiedene,
zusätzliche Abmachungen
und Regeln dazu.
Ähm, im ersten Moment
bin ich darüber immer verärgert.
Aber im Endeffekt wird schon alles
seine Richtigkeit haben.
Zweimal in der Woche muss ich z.B.
100 % der Frühstücksbutter essen.
Oder, ähm ...
... einen Joghurt mit Zucker.
Ja, ich versuche mal,
nicht aufzugeben.
* Scheppern *
Möchten Sie auch Wasser?
- Ich habe meine Flasche.
Samira hat Fortschritte gemacht.
Sie lässt sich
sogar beim Essen filmen.
Alle alten Gewohnheiten
hat sie noch nicht abgelegt.
Die Sauce z.B. bleibt Tabu.
Man kann mich daran aufhängen,
dass ich diese Sauce nicht esse,
aber Sauce
esse ich nachher auch nicht.
Wenn ich aber
z.B. in einem Restaurant bin,
habe ich kein Problem,
die Sauce zu essen,
solange das nicht täglich
der Fall ist.
Nur noch wenige Tage,
dann kann Samira wieder nach Hause.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
* Scheppern *
Ich bin zufrieden.
Ich bin am Abbauen.
Es wird jeden Tag
ein halbes Milligramm weniger,
seit Montag.
Teilweise bin ich einfach ...
habe ich ...
... massive Stimmungsschwankungen.
Das reicht?
- Ja.
Reto spürt zum ersten Mal seit Langem
wieder, wie es ohne Drogen ist.
* Reibgeräusch *
Das Problem ist: Ob ich etwas nehmen
oder nicht - es ist mir unwohl.
Ja, ich habe längere Zeit
nicht mehr im Beruf gearbeitet.
Vorher arbeitete ich
zwölf Jahre im Beruf.
Ich möchte wieder
als Metallbauer arbeiten,
auf Montage
oder auch in der Werkstatt.
Reto ist gelernter Metallbauer
und sucht einen Job
für die Zeit nach der Klinik.
Er weiss,
dass er eine Beschäftigung braucht,
wenn er nicht wieder
rückfällig werden will.
Okay. In dem Fall bis morgen.
Gleichfalls.
Auf Wiederhören, Herr Zürcher.
Es läuft was.
Ja, es ...
Ich habe immer etwas,
aber nie etwas Definitives.
Das ist das Problem.
* Er räuspert sich. *
Das wäre als ...
Ein Einsatz als Metallbauer,
aber halt temporär.
Aber manchmal
kann aus einer temporären Arbeit
auch eine Festanstellung werden.
Auch Reto macht verschiedene
Therapien, heute Kunsttherapie.
Aufgrund des Entzugs hat er Mühe.
Nein, das ist nichts.
Ah!
30, plus 30.
Verflixt noch einmal!
Ich hätte es gehabt.
Es wäre schon gut gewesen, Mann!
Er hat viele Ressourcen.
Er hat Fähigkeiten.
Ich habe aber den Eindruck,
dass er sich manchmal überschätzt.
Und danach ...
Und dann bringt er die Geduld
und Disziplin nicht mehr auf.
Dadurch ist er wieder gefrustet.
Und dann neigt er dazu, zu etwas zu
greifen, das ihn wieder entlastet.
Hier in der Klinik
ist das nur der Tabak.
Reto weiss aber, dass es draussen
wieder anders sein kann.
Seit vier Wochen bist du hier.
- Drei Wochen.
Drei Wochen und drei Tage.
Und alles abgebaut, oder?
Es ist schneller wieder aufgebaut,
als abgebaut,
das ist das Problem.
Etwas zuversichtlich bist du schon?
- Nein.
Wieso nicht?
Weil ich schon schon
zum elften Mal hier bin.
* Surren *
Du fühlst dich einfach ...
Komisch. Es nervt mich alles.
Ich bin unkonzentriert.
Und dann immer noch
die Scheisskamera.
Tu sie mal weg, Mann!
* Lockere Gitarrenklänge *
Auch Cahit sucht einen Job.
Hier in der Pizzeria
kennt er den Chef persönlich.
Noch etwas reden.
Evtl. hat er einen Job für mich.
Er hat eine Taxifirma. Mal schauen.
* Stimmengewirr *
Hallo.
Nazif Saglam
ist ein Freund der Familie.
Er hat ein Taxiunternehmen
und Cahit versprochen,
die Augen für ihn offen zu halten.
Er hat mir schon lange gesagt:
"Ich suche."
Kannst du nicht Taxi fahren?
- Ja, doch.
Taxi bin ich noch nie gefahren.
Ausbildung?
Ich habe eine Fahrschule
für die Taxi-Ausbildung.
Regionaltaxi 121.
- Hast du?
Habe ich.
Ich nehme ihn gleich mit,
nach Seebach ins Büro.
Ins Theorielokal.
Kein Witz.
Ja, doch. Sicher. Im Moment
ist der Führerausweis das Problem.
Ich musste ihn abgeben.
Wenn Cahit den Job haben will, muss
er sofort den Cannabiskonsum stoppen.
Will er seinen Führerausweis zurück,
muss er ein halbes Jahr lang
Urinproben abgeben.
D.h., ab sofort nie mehr kiffen
und aufhören zu trinken.
Genau, genau.
* Sanfte,
nachdenkliche Gitarrenklänge *
Ein paar Tage später
in einem illegalen Internetcafe.
Die eigentliche Sucht
meldet sich zurück - das Spielen.
Cahit verspielt sein ganzes Geld
für einen Monat,
an einem einzigen Abend.
* Klagende Musik *
* Langgezogener Geigenton *
Wie viel?
- Etwa 780 Fr. habe ich erhalten.
Also das alles.
Weisst du, warum du es gemacht hast?
Was ist passiert?
Es ist knapp für den ganzen Monat.
780 sind ...
Ich habe offene Rechnungen.
Bussen, die gezahlt werden müssen.
Bei ein paar Kollegen
habe ich noch Schulden.
Beim einen 200 Fr.,
beim anderen 200 Fr.
Mit 780 Fr.
kann ich das nicht alles bezahlen.
Um die Schulden bezahlen zu können,
hoffte er auf den grossen Gewinn.
Wie immer ohne Erfolg.
Zwei Tage lang
wirklich unter Schock.
Man weiss nicht mehr,
was man machen soll.
Schämst du dich auch etwas?
Ja, schon.
Ich bin keine 18 oder 19 mehr.
Du machst das
im Alter von 46, 47 Jahren.
Vorhin hat deine Mutter angerufen.
Weiss sie, dass du noch spielst?
Sie merkt sofort, dass ich ...
Die wissen das alles.
Wie merken sie es?
Wenn ich um 20 Uhr
zu ihr nach Hause zum Essen gehe,
dann weiss sie,
dass ich keine Kohle mehr habe.
Ich gehe bei ihr essen
und sie sagt sofort,
ich hätte wieder alles verloren.
Was antwortest du?
Ja, was sage ich? Nein, ja, so ...
Sie merkt es sofort.
* Nachdenkliche Gitarrenmusik *
Guten Morgen und happy Halloween!
Ich bin extra früher aufgestanden.
Ich war auch nicht laufen, damit ich
mein wahres Ich zeigen kann.
* Sie schnieft. *
Ich fühle mich immer wohler.
Dazu muss ich sagen,
dass ich etwas abgenommen habe.
Darüber bin ich sehr froh
und ich bin sehr stolz darauf.
Und das trotz dieser ...
... für mich schlechten Ernährung.
Es klappt immer besser.
Das macht mich happy Halloween.
Nach drei Monaten
ist heute Samiras letzter Tag
im stationären Aufenthalt.
Beim Eintritt waren Sie ...
... 66,4 kg.
Jetzt, beim Austritt
sind es 59,2 kg.
Ja.
- Mhm.
Ich bin erstaunt, dass ich durch -
ich sage mal - normale Ernährung,
trotzdem das Gewicht,
das ich mir durch meine Fressatta-
cken angetan habe, verloren habe.
Mit ihrer Therapeutin schaut Samira,
wie es weitergehen soll.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
So.
Haben Sie heute Ihren grossen Tag?
Ja, das kann man so sagen.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Gut.
Welches sind die Ziele
für die nächsten Tage?
In den nächsten Tagen
will ich sicher zu Hause
mein Essverhalten
so weiterführen können,
respektive nicht wieder
zum Kontrollfreak werden
und alles abwiegen ...
... genau notieren, tracken
und was auch immer.
Der Nachteil ist, dass Sie sich
selbst viel Druck machen.
Ja, gerade wenn es
um diese Disziplin geht.
Viele beneiden das und ich wünschte,
ich hätte weniger davon
oder ich könnte auch mal sagen:
"Heute ist es egal."
"Heute esse ich, worauf ich Lust
habe und ich trainiere nicht."
"Es ist kein Problem,
es ändert nichts an mir."
Das fällt mir schwer.
In der Klinik sind auch
Freundschaften entstanden.
Jetzt heisst es Abschied nehmen.
Du meldest dich, du bist im Chat.
- Ja, mache ich.
Wir glauben an dich.
- Hast du alles?
Ich gehe,
sonst muss ich noch einmal weinen.
Tschüss.
- (Alle) Tschau.
Samira muss ab jetzt wieder
alleine zurechtkommen.
Sie besucht zwar weiterhin
in der Klinik die Therapiestunden,
aber sie wohnt zu Hause und ist fürs
Essen und Training verantwortlich.
* Miauen *
(Leise) Vielleicht abends.
Das Schlimmste wäre,
wenn ich wieder ...
Wenn ich meine Essattacken
nicht in den Griff kriege
oder ich sogar
wieder welche bekomme.
Ja! Du! Ist das lässig?
Und, äh ...
Dass ich das Essen wieder so ...
... strikt halte ...
und ich wieder damit beginne,
mir Dinge über eine längere Zeit
hinweg extrem zu verbieten
und es dann wieder
in Essattacken ausartet.
Das wäre im Moment
für mich das Schlimmste.
* Sanfte, nachdenkliche Musik *
Auch Reto
hat heute seinen Austrittstag.
Ich habe gedacht,
ich bereite schon alles vor.
Reto geht auf eigenen Wunsch
wieder nach Hause.
Irgendwie bin ich froh,
dass ich nach Hause kann.
Aber es ist nicht so ...
Ich bin auch schon raus und
habe überall gesagt, es komme gut -
und ich schaffte es
nicht einmal bis nach Hause.
Ich bin voll überzeugt hier raus.
Es ist besser,
wenn man etwas gefasst ist.
Jetzt ist es
eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Also ...
- Eine gute Zeit.
Alles Gute!
- Vielen Dank für alles.
Wenn ich unfreundlich war,
war es nicht persönlich gemeint.
Ich habe es nie persönlich genommen.
Ich kenne Sie doch.
Es war mehr wegen des Entzugs,
wenn ich nicht so viel gesagt habe.
* Er murmelt. *
* Sanfte Musik *
Wir gehen vorne raus.
- Ja.
* Reto seufzt. *
Das war wirklich
ein entsetzliches Chaos.
Es ist immer noch eines.
Reto ist wieder zu Hause und erhält
als Erstes eine gute Nachricht.
Du hast einen Job?
Ja, einfach temporär.
Cahit reist zu seinen Wurzeln.
Dort kommt er zur Einsicht.
15 Jahre lang ...
... war ich wie nicht am Leben.
Samira fällt zurück in alte Muster.
Ich habe auch gemerkt,
ähm, dass ich es
nicht aufgeben muss.
Sie lernt aber auch, das Leben
endlich wieder zu geniessen.